[Music]
well new insight into nevada's latino
voters research from emerson college
shows the economy is the most important
issue but as politics now host john
langler explains latinos don't trust
either party to help
latinos make up around 20 percent of
nevada's voters it's a crucial part of
our population that could swing the
midterm elections one way or the other
so we have new polling from emerson
college and it shows both parties have a
lot of work to do earning their trust as
with most things political it starts and
ends with the economy in the emerson
college poll 37 percent of latinos think
the economy and inflation are the most
important issues housing is a distant
second followed by something else
interestingly latinos don't think either
party is best to deal with it 32 percent
don't trust democrats or republicans to
navigate the country's economic
challenges 23 percent lean towards
republicans on the issue 21 democrats
in this
country in this country in this state in
this
city
and we know that every time we go to the
store the prices seem to be higher and
higher and higher fernando romero leads
hispanics in politics the oldest latino
political group in nevada i don't see
too many uh speaking
on the economy and i don't see those
that just how
we're going to be able to solve
that particular
matter the problem the indecisiveness
stretches into party support and
presidential approval emerson college's
polling found 36 percent are neutral on
president biden's performance 34 percent
are negative 30 percent positive it's
more decisive for former president trump
the new poll shows 47 percent of latinos
in nevada have a negative view of him 30
percent are neutral 23 percent are
positive it's not a matter of party it's
a matter of what the parties are doing
or not doing
the democrats are addressing what some
of our concerns are
the republicans are not among nevada
latinos voters and non-voters 42 percent
are neutral on democrats 49 percent on
republicans it's a sign both parties
have to work on their message in the
months leading up to november
john langler live local now